comme de manière générale c'est toujours
organisés évidemment pour la victoire de
tous les noms j'étais chez moi d'accord
travers s'étaient organisés évidemment
comme pour tous les candidats évidemment
marine le pen v j'imagine organisé aussi
quelque chose de son avis en un mélange
il commande en même temps que la paire
me dois de
williams et les malades est la concorde
c'est gagné ouais ça qu'en corse a gagné
et au pavillon d'armenonville si elle
perdit voilà le danger en fait avec les
images d'une victoire à la
présidentielle en tout cas les premières
images c'est qu'elle vous colle pour
l'intégralité des mandats on l'a vu que
nicolas sarkozy est le fouquet's hurle
avec françois hollande et le baiser
forcé de valérie trierweiler macron se
souvient de lui avec le louvre et avec
beethoven là le danger c'est qu'on se
souvienne de quoi du dj et des ministres
quittant alors juste un moment où
effectivement bien sûr et à un moment où
le front de faire le rassemblement
national il est extrêmement haut donc
d'oran termes de résultats ça pose
question et ça serait handicapant pour
emmanuel macron de traîner cette image
un petit peu de alors de désinvolture
sachant que emmanuel macron a fait comme
un discours totalement différent
que que ce que ça fait puisque ça a été
un discours très sobre empreint
d'humilité alors à 20h lors de l'annoncé
des résultats les militants et proches
des manuels maintenant est laissé
éclater leur joie de voir le président
réélu c'est normal mais très rapidement
à 20h07 le dj de la soirée dj vanetti a
envoyé le titre de daft punk
tout le monde a parlé moi je me demande
c'est quoi ils ont dû 0 est une idée
d'où
les gars j'ai une idée de ouf si on
gagne c'est quoi
et à toi ouest et dont il ya toujours un
ou deux lieux vainqueur des watts
mais c'est sûr le gars a dû arriver là
derrière les gars on va mettre times
c'est quoi ouais bah oui
quoi partie
[Musique]
sans elle j'ai adoré le one more time
avec le truc derrière j'avais
l'impression frères des jeans idole avec
la promo sur le saucisson
les chéris cette semaine sur mes
positions sur le juste après le moins
d'un pour cent bien scientifique ou non
mais sans déconner exceptionnelle
à les termes étaient là avec
[Musique]
tu es à l'abeille et n'aurait cessé
c'est incroyable franchement c'est
improbable j'avais l'impression d'être
chez flunch oui
j'imagine pour eux extrêmement difficile
parce qu'il faut résoudre une équation
qui est insoluble il faut d'un côté
célébrer une victoire et en même temps
ne pas la célébrer c'est à dire qu'il
faut pas avec c'est une partie des
français parce qu'on sait que il ya une
vraie déception et ses quelques il ya eu
un taux d'abstention qui est record et
c'est donc il faut quand même envoyé un
signal fort tout en disant à ses parts
propres partisans et à ceux qui ont
quand même joué le jeu entre guillemets
républicain ben oui on a on est quand
même contents d'être là donc c'est une
équation impossible à résoudre on a faim
on a on a comparé des images non de la
victoire de la fête en 2017 à et les
images d'hier et loire
[Musique]
g
oh
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
thomas n'gijol cela choucroute avancer
la côte de porc
on est ensemble et retrouver nos en
rayon le pays
cette semaine aux éau lingerie chez lidl
de barresi à -50 et coquine
berne
c'est toujours jean marc chez lidl je me
trouve actuellement au rayon des eaux
et pour devenir homo achetés à des eaux
d'oran larousse offert aux attentes elle
attendait pour traquer manuela croyante
et du président
sans déconner mais les annonces
exceptionnelles ce soit et puis c'est
vrai qu'on 2017 y avait un côté surprise
avec une vraie ferveur on voit aussi
avoir un vrai truc alors que la en 2022
c'est plus pudique
je suis au rayon meubles de jardin
[Applaudissements]
on était quand vous voulez sans état de
grâce en fait donc beaucoup plus sobre
la fête elle est même presque fabrique
et on apprend qu'ils juin dans ce sens
vraiment danser alors qu'elle avait un
vrai truc en 2017 et pendant
c'est toujours dommage je suis
actuellement au rayon céréales avec
frostis qu'est ce qu'on va manger bien
entendu du tigre et grâce à l'idole jeu
pour 2 caps et roger paquet monti
d'acheter est tout chaud qu'on vous
seront offerts marc tixador
affaires sanitaires
oui moi je trouve sa catastrophique en
terme de communication n'y avait pas de
fête au bois de boulogne
voilà c'est ça n'a aucun sens c'est
catastrophique déjà pardon cette
histoire n est pas écrasant donc y'a
rien à fêter
mairie pendant sa soeur qu'il allait
paix l'attendait vont nous même temps
que c'est la guerre que la france est
divisée en deux et fracturés quelques
ovide pas où il ya des gens qui peuvent
toujours pas aller bosser et là ils font
l'atelier bas ils allaient s'affronter
votre serviteur se trouve actuellement
au rayon et serviettes
bien fait signe alors quand même je
l'avais
acheté il vous est offert on se retrouve
tout à l'heure je monte tout de suite au
rayon bricolage
fossé entre la majeure part de la
population qui vit sous la menace d'un
pacte d'actionnaires est gentil dallaire
qui peuvent pas travailler et cetera ce
sont surtout mécontents du résultat
va pas nous créons pas montré une foule
comme ça
percer c'est bien mais bricoler c'est
mieux avec la télé caire cette semaine
pour deux personnes acheter à bon
touchant au vert pour raboter sans
souffrance
oui c'est une secte soit vous n'en
faites pas là ils ont pris à vide gec
est très peu connue qui est pas très bon
là
dessus c'est le gars le gaillet très
bien
mais c'est un support ils ont raison
c'est insupportable
l'étude qui t'a fait défaut de mariage
et je fais
ensuite ils voulaient bien tout réfléchi
ils ont même pas réussi à faire
scintiller la tour eiffel il a fallu
retarder du secours alors est-ce qu'elle
satie par la presse at il à toi
peut-être fait scintiller mois mais
jamais fait ça avec des meufs commet une
faute sur les meufs là
tout le monde l'appelle c'est avec des
matches un moment que je devrais comme
ça aurait fait comme ça et je recycle
pas si tu en as c'est quoi s'amuser
il polit dur à redon exactement et yvan
attal et des films préférés ouais mon
brave voyons pas on se recentre sur ses
retombées sur certains points sur tout
mais sur les centres non on sur rien
mais suffisamment merci de la
marseillaise c'est pas si vous allez le
montrer mais c'est une calamité la
marseillaise est obligé de repartir à
zéro sur la leur juste savoir d'abord
faire un terrain
juste y en a at il une dent il ya de la
danse de la polémique ils ont été très
choqués par mois le mental
[Rires]
qui a effectué l'été n'arrivait pas
il arrive et à grands pas c'est pour
cette raison que je me trouve au rayon
maillot
une pièce deux pièces faites vous
plaisir ici tout est magnifique et bien
sûr une femme sera belle en une pièce en
deux pièces l'important c'est qu'elle ne
soit pas nul comme gilbert neige merci
il danse il ya une danse 7,2 ministre la
danse de joël je dois le dire ou es
barbara pompili dante une opa en paix et
ils se sont mis à danser comme au
mariage de leur oncle à oui ça a
beaucoup fait réagir aux gardes et
j'avais l'impression d'avoir tabac
et on que janot regarder
[Musique]
et
de plus il a choqué
moi j'ai adoré ce à quoi ça sert pas
trace des jeunes en salle danse et d'art
galeristes toi toi tout mal c'est alors
que marine le pen a annoncé je trouvais
ça d'arc a aussi bien franchement faut
arrêter arènes de cordoue mal partout
ils ont aidé à le penser ils ont droit
qui sait ce qu'est ce qui se passe est
insupportable
non mais qu'est ce que tu as mais non
mais rien n'est certain et negri du tout
ses ennemis si personne ne connaît ce
ministre alors avec un titre plutôt
poser c'est à dire mais moi je vais pas
danser comme ça c'est facile
mais témoin
c'est encore jean-marc quand on reçoit
des amis on est bien content d'avoir des
petits trucs à grignoter nous sommes au
rayon bonne veine cacahuètes et jean moi
d'ailleurs béninois sachez que pour ne
pas qu et de cacahuètes acheter un
paquet hipster où sera offert au rayon
lidl cacahuètes le deuxième étage elle
vous attend
alors
cherchez le mec dans les rues à les
embêter
j'ai envie de quoi devrait
avoir un jardin c'est sympa mais bon
gardien avec un gazon bien entendu
c'est ce que vous propose chenni donne
au troisième étage au rayon jardinage
venez nous voir et vous allez voir notre
tondeuse à nérac jamais chez le groupe
mais quand pub qui vont du bon match
images à bayonne est ce qu'il faut faire
si tu n'as pas honte de faire ça les
mêmes pavés c'est exceptionnel il ya eu
une autre scène hier qu'on a vu c'est à
20 heures lorsque les résultats sont
tombés on a vu plein de ministres se
faire des bisous et des câlins on avait
l'impression qu'il avait gagné la coupe
du monde regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais moi
qui a dit que les produits laitiers
n'était plus dans l'année pour la vigne
je suis au rayon yaourts et pour de
yaourts yoplait acheter on célèbre à
tous pour danette et où pourrait
repartir avec votre crème dessert
danette donnant donnant il y aura
également de la mont-blanc à tout à
l'heure pour d'autres pays
commencent à coûter cette histoire trois
avions à peu près alors là franchement
je pourrais même pas vous dire
honnêtement millions ça coûte forcément
20 millions ça qu'on s'est
fait à un million la jp la circoncision
à mon avis ça va coûter regardez
pour la jetée dans le jardin des gens
qu'elle cherchait
ça coûte forcément évidemment ça a un
coût évidemment assez important après
c'est aussi le début d'un nouveau
quinquennat entre guillemets donc
normalement c'est censé être réussie
c'est censé être entre guillemets
parfait il est censé y avoir évidemment
de l'enthousiasmé etc c'est vrai que la
comparaison vous avez fait tout à
l'heure on le voit l'enthousiasmé
n'était pas là on l'a vu après on voit
aussi que comme le feront demain comme
le rassemblement national est très haut
on sentait aussi de toute façon dans
cette campagne qu'il y avait très peu
d'enthousiasmé il n'y avait pas de
billets pas de cette joie qu'on pouvait
ressentir cette expérience qu'on
pourrait ressentir en 2017 je pense
qu'il n'a pas vu est content quand même
hein je crois qu'on avait quitté content
et gilles verdez a tué parce qu'il a
fait mais après toi hier soir est à dire
jacques abeille résultat à d'accord avec
la banda regard des résultats avec fat
ou encore une soirée réussie
juste après le discours d' emmanuel
macron qu'à marquer des espèces et farah
el dib aynaoui une mezzo soprano qui a
chanté la marseillaise sauf que tout ne
s'est pas passé comme prévu la pauvreté
il ya eu ce qu'on a eu ce qu'on appelle
un faux départ
[Applaudissements]
marchons marchons
qu'un sang
sion
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon ça va c'est bon ça
la mettant les aléas du direct en
belgique à chanter mais bien sûr moi
j'étais je suis sûr qu emmanuel macron à
l'oreille elle est formidable elle est
accro à mesure qu'ils manuellement
coincé comme à sony sehic
si j'ai brisé que son père hal je
connais absents fait sensation
c'est sûr et certain qu'il verra buy com
il est au congo emmanuel macron de ce
qui va les voir comme bien sûr locaux
bien sûr les autres grammes il est
validé choisi la chanteuse très connue
de grade paris sa prestation hier soir
au froid oui
c'est une journée qui fait stabiliser
moi j'ai kiffé moi
j'ai trouvé des lycéens quand lycées et
des bas mais je me suis dit c'est hyper
sûr jeter comme à givet sehic frérot c
est qu est ce qui fait qu elle a raconté
qu'en fait on l'a prévenu les équipes de
production de emmanuel macron ont
prévenu samedi après-midi à répéter mais
il a fallu qu'elle prenne un travail
dimanche matin donc y avait quand même
un petit côté un pointu et improvisé ce
qui donne sens à l'aise
en
fait ça a pas créé l'émotion qui devait
être susciter je pense malheureusement
que le départ a dû la déstabiliser la
voie enfin je suis pas un expert en
chansons mais la voie moi m'a pas semblé
parler mais
voilà que c'était pas c'était pas comme
ça que ça devait se passer c'est pas ça
créait ce que vous avez eu les poils
alors en vrai je vois que tu dises
vraiment la vérité voilà je m'en bats
toi c'est ça mais tu es force mon jeu
l'air années que je suis un petit ça
veut dire mais tu sais même pas comment
oui c'est vraiment ce qui est drôle
c'est que suis pas sûr que moi si marine
le pen et hier soir que je serai sur un
d un plateau de télé ce soir en train de
critiquer la chanteuse qu'elle a choisis
sur mer sa fille pas tant que ça allait
vraiment bien sûr garde n'avait jamais
voté ouais j'ai jamais été critiqué leur
soirée c'est une soirée on s'en fout et
on rigole ça va emmerder non on est dans
six ans charles plus on répétait alors
vous
marier tout le monde là ça y est on
regarder puisque huit ça y est il assez
le moment de la charia pour la saison au
pavillon d'armenonville ah oui un
message on va y aller on va aller
partout vous inquiétez pas on a charrié
tout le monde ici nous tourner tout le
monde tout le monde se fait charrier ici
même mois